alright what is up everybody happy
weekend it is actually friday night for
us I know it's Sunday while you guys are
watching this but it's Friday night for
us and we have our annual Toronto dance
salsa halloween party and I thought I
would take you behind the scenes of what
we're doing what we're dressing up and
share in the fun of what we do tonight
so here we go what are we gonna be this
year we're gonna bathe in jail do this
just don't do this this says ninja and
Chinese I know well chinese and japanese
i know because i can speak chinese
hahahaha okay more i married a chinese
person i like like your mass goes all
the way I Milan hello we're fully in
yeah ninja style we need salsa friendly
costumes look at Nina's eyes so we gotta
go eat in our ninja outfits what I do
this with a vengeance no this is what I
do ninja ninja is
okay we got it we gotta go eat and they
get fit thinking to the club to teach a
lesson in our ninja outfits so every
year Nina pics our costumes she does all
the work I don't think this year she
even told me what it was not she nobody
didn't tell me till I came I think no I
did I told you yes I did I totally
remembered that too so uh that smells
really bad so neither does all the work
because if it were up to me I reply just
go as a baseball player every year or
something something simple but I
appreciate all the work I got to tell
you these things feel like I'm in
pajamas these are really comfortable I
might have to wear ninja pajamas duh cuz
there's those are really comfortable
nylon nylon don't know what it is but ok
to the car some food my spies are to
lose at the soy ok just good go I just
don't get it isn't this what else our
way oh that's not the answer it's not
the answer ok let's get some food let's
get some nice food and then hit the pds
not tds up hella appellate for a party
so it's kind of a tradition for us on
uptown la salsa party nights that we go
to Kenzo ramen it has some Kinzel ramen
it's green right
oh sweet japanese a couple of ninjas
going to a japanese restaurant business
so Nina is having what is this really I
never thought you'd have who's driving
there shoyu ramen ramen and i have the
japanese curry with some yummy soup and
salad dig in we're in the middle of the
street jaywalking to get to uptown love
there goes Nina running around running
around this is it yes hola
we hold parties here usually vote twice
a month we have a couple big parties
every year we have the halloween party
we've got the Valentine's party any
other big parties Christmas trees you do
at TDS look at these decorations what's
up man we got witches and bats and
skeletons and spiderwebs oh and red
lights look at that very bloody I like
it man so you know I'm gonna get set up
teach our combo then continue on with
the night shall we begin Rosanna is that
as AB I same butterfly ladybug late
presenting the ladybug alex is a unicorn
I Love Lucy I love lily I love Lily Lucy
there's Stephanie some fries a pilot
whoa my gosh what's that man he's a
police I love it ninja Nina yeah
violence I didn't notice the melt before
an award no but this is a mouth is am
radio satellite hello okay let's hear
some radio javi right now ten-year
Backstreet Boys
have some boys
Fernando our upcoming bachata instructor
doing some Michael Jackson moves brought
some some musical instruments in Cuba
customized look at that Oh guys gonna
have to play it I love it thanks man I
love it we are done we are done what
time is it such it touching up that late
we're done that was a good night how you
feelin me now oh oh sorry I thought
you're just talking to me and I didn't
know that you do
look at your the great mood this is such
a great mood up the cameras and turned a
look at the picture let me see the
picture where we got going on here
seemed I didn't put that in there you go
look at that my ninja my Chinese ninja
we're going home message of the day you
want to close on here what's your fun
all the time what I like that message it
is don't have to get out you gotta have
fun all the time doesn't matter what
there is a halloween dress up anytime
have fun all the time i feel like i need
to put that clip on at home to something
like if you come home and the kitchen
I'd be messy it's like have fun all the
time you know I remember your message
thank you guys I needed that that's
amazing this is great work okay well
we're going to go off and get some sleep
early morning tomorrow thank you guys
for joining us hopefully yours you had
an amazing Halloween to go out and dance
go and have some fun go and express some
creativity and don't care what people
think or say do you that's it do you
Nina's doing her right now always right
do you continue to believe guys I can't
use my hand believe hey let me do it
okay Eileen believe oh I like that that
had some good i'll take the tone there
and and what else Cena whatever what
your one where it is and what else I'll
see you soon but we'll see you soon
we're see you soon bye bye bye